former President George Herbert Walker
Bush his service dog Sully is preparing
for a new role at the end of the month
the two year old Labrador will start
working with veterans at Walter Reed
National Military Medical Center in
Maryland he helped comfort President
Bush during the last months of his life
in a poignant photograph the lab was
seen watching over his casket chip Reid
met Sully at a training facility on Long
Island chip good morning well good
morning service dogs like Sully are
trained to serve those who have served
this country they support veterans and
first responders with daily tasks and
help mitigate the symptoms of PTSD they
also provide comfort to vets in need and
that is what Sully did for President
Bush it was a photograph that touched
the nation's soul
Sully President George HW Bush's service
dog paying his last respects that photo
will forever memorialize their
relationship and yeah I'm getting chills
right now we've been thinking about it
John Miller is CEO of America's vet dogs
the charity that trained so he says they
were a perfect match and I think it was
Sully's old soul so to speak that really
what I'm over with the president he's
named for that other Sully Sully
Sullenberger who landed his plane on the
Hudson River saving the lives of
everyone on board as far as we know this
Sully can't land a plane on a river but
he can do some pretty amazing things
Valerie Kramer is his trainer
that's the kind of task he did for
President Bush but a big part of his job
was simply giving comfort as the
president mourned the death of Barbara
his wife of 73 years he would lie at his
feet similar to how he is lying at your
feet now I am really good company shake
well thank you very much dogs from
America's vet dogs don't just help
presidents they've served thousands of
veterans including dennis chips has
Felix changed your life 100% after 11
years in the Navy and navy reserve he
was diagnosed with post-traumatic stress
disorder there's been times weren't even
planned trips to Walmart three o'clock
in the morning just to avoid people
Felix comforts chips when he shows signs
of stress and wakes him from frequent
nightmares pokel up and nudge my side
and then place his head on my chest
chips is retiring soon from his job as a
prison guard you'll be with him all the
time that's it 24/7 is he ever gonna
leave your side
not once Valerie Kramer is about to have
the opposite experience losing Sully to
his next mission where he'll assist
veterans Atwater Reed Hospital in
Maryland he's gonna make people smile
every day he's got this fantastic trot
in his ears just flap about and you just
can't not smile yes it costs $50,000 to
Train one service dog but the veterans
don't pay a penny it's all paid by
America's vet dogs and by the way it was
President Bush's decision to send Sully
to Walter Reed where he will wear his
vest with the presidential seal so
everyone will know who he is I think
they know you're right there's nothing
you can't smile help but smile when you
see them especially when they're running
in slow motion that the ears going back
I'm still watching that pay attention
some ways the former president still
doing service to this country
another veteran
point yeah thank you chip I know you
love dogs so just a little